no olvidar nunca a las víctimas del
holocausto ni repetir las atrocidades
del pasado este fue el mensaje que lanzó
el presidente francés emmanuel marco
este jueves día internacional de la
memoria del holocausto en un tuit mccrum
se comprometió a no ceder nunca ante
quienes intentan dar e inscribir la
historia esto sí johann compromiso el
jueves por la noche en un evento
organizado por el congreso judío europeo
combo la lucha que compartimos es una
lucha esencial para la civilización
europea y para francia como nación y
como república civilización esta lucha
por desgracia se ha convertido en una
realidad una vez más ya que se han
levantado de nuevo vientos adversos y se
han instalado ciertas ideas el
aniversario de la liberación de
auschwitz birkenau el mayor campo de
exterminio nazi por parte del ejército
rojo en 1945 es la fecha elegida por la
unión europea para el día internacional
del recuerdo del holocausto el jueves
ante el parlamento europeo en bruselas
la alemana mago philander superviviente
del holocausto subrayó la importancia de
mostrar la humanidad
y se eleva
yo misma he tenido la experiencia de
cómo la gente ha negado a otras personas
esa humanidad esto no debe volver a
ocurrir por eso ahora debemos estar
atentos y no mirar hacia otro lado como
hicimos entonces si el odio el racismo y
el antisemitismo no deben ser la última
palabra de la historia
he tenido que ver con mis propios ojos y
experiencia a dónde conduce esto en 2022
se cumplen 77 años de la liberación del
campo y lander advirtió que el
antisemitismo está aumentando mientras
que el presidente de la comisión europea
prometió no cerrar los ojos a la
historia